little little words can make a big
difference right and so the key word
that you need to have a look for when
we're talking about centers of motion is
the word about now about such a general
word you might think what does it have
to do with anything right I want to coil
mine all the way back to like u7
geometry when when you talk about
symmetry rotational symmetry
reflectional symmetry and we would say
reflect this you know reflect this shape
about and then we would give you a line
and we'd say okay that means you reflect
across that you don't just reflect it
over here or wherever you want you have
to look at that line in particular or we
might say here is a shape right and I
would like you to rotate it but I just
want you to rotate it anywhere I want
you to rotate it about a particular
point like say that right which is why
you won't just get a shape on top of
itself you would get for instance
something like this that's the pivot
point right so when you see the word
about it actually means something very
specific in our context that the center
of motion is whatever is about to come
after the word about okay usually they
will say about the origin okay but in
some cases today will not and that's all
we're gonna have a look at in question
twelve so let's stay with black read
along with me the particle moves
according to and then they give you this
equation let's write that equation down
together x equals three minus two T okay
so when they want you to see that a
particle is moving and it's not about
the origin they will do this generally
speaking in one of two ways they will
either use the O method I was just
talking to you about they'll say about
and then they'll provide you the center
of motion if they're feeling charitable
but other times they will not tell you
what the center of motion is they will
just give you an equation and in inside
tucked into that equation if you work
with it which is what they asked us to
do you will find the center of motion is
somewhere else so they say that's in
terms of centimeters and seconds and
then in Part A they say use
trigonometric identities to put the
equation into a different form so let's
write down what that form is it says
x equals x naught minus a cons and take
right now before we embark on this thing
let's just point out the things about
this that are familiar okay
firstly if I just hide this guy here if
I just hide that tell me what you know
about the motion of this particle you
know lots of things
it starts at it starts at okay hold on
it doesn't let's looks I'll gonna take
the idea that you said which is correct
but I'm gonna be a little Worcester to
be right this time this particle does
not start at the origin yeah this one
okay when we begin being given like
information about something they say
come up with the equation we generally
choose sign or cause based on where we
start okay now this will not start the
origin but doesn't quite start at one
either and you already fixed it up where
does it start it starts at a okay what
else can you tell me what is this thing
tell us this is gonna tell us the period
like how quickly it waves up and down
okay what about the fact that I mean
yeah okay I'll leave it there now I'll
put this here now okay how about that
what does that tell you now it's been
flipped upside down so it's still going
to be moving in the same way but now
like to begin with what direction is it
going in its going think think what does
cause normally do cause normally starts
up here and it sort of goes down right
so now we've actually turned upside down
so it's started down here and it's
increasing it's going up okay and then
lastly they've slapped this guy on right
so what effect does that have on the
graph yeah it's it shifts it it slides
it up X naught units okay so this
changes where where the whole thing is
moving around so this guy here you might
want to highlight this right this is
going to be your center of motion it
used to be origin but you've taken the
entire thing you've gone soup or
depending on where the X naught is
negative you might have taken it down
okay but this is the center of motion
here okay
so now we know what what on earth were
actually dealing with now can we get
from here to here how do we do it well
they've already given us a big clue
they're not going to give you these
clues later on to use trigonometric
trigonometric identities and you can see
what I've got has got a cos squared in
it and what I end with does not have a
cos squared in it okay so what should
you think about the trigonometric
identities that you know that relate
cause Squared's with just regular old
causes have a think maybe a write-off on
the slide here what identity could we
use that has a cos squared in it that
will also have cosines in it cos 2theta
oh I mean this anymore
maybe you want to write cos 2theta on
the right-hand side over here with me
and we'll have a think about this we
haven't worked explicitly with trig
identities for a little while so
hopefully by the time we do this a few
times it will start to become more
familiar with you but for now we need to
remember what's going on here cos 2theta
does have cosines in it it's got a cos
squared like so it has something else as
well doesn't it it has a minus sine
squared now if you have a great memory
you will also know that there are two
alternative forms to this and you'll
have them in your memory and you'll know
those actually gonna be much more useful
because I have no signs in here at all
right but if you're like me then you do
not remember those because you get the
sines flipped backwards and you're like
bears one has a two and one doesn't ever
- you don't remember which ones which
so I always remember this one and then I
get whichever other one I need off the
basis of this okay if I've only got
cosines and I don't want any signs what
should I do to this sine squared okay so
I can I can do a division right that
will turn everything into like tan and
SEC and like oh thing so that might be
handy if I have ten or SEC here in this
case I do not what's something else I
could do that would work but for
something else with this okay I can use
the Pythagorean identity sine squared
plus cos squared equals one which tells
me this well it was a bad idea to use
this I can replace the sine squared with
this are you okay with that
that's the same as sine squared over
there so if I rearrange now just a teeny
bit you can see
I'm gonna have a double negative here so
I'm gonna get to kind of squared theta
minus 1 are you ok with that
how's that yeah like I said I'm some of
you and I hope if you're feel like yeah
I'm always the one who runs out of time
in an exam right you need to be able to
call on this immediately you need to
have that authority in that memory but
if you're like I can't remember it I
know that I'm going to remember it wrong
that's the trouble that I always had
then come back to this we're always
pretty good with that in comparison and
then get this from there ok now can I
use that over here directly
I'm never so close I have to tweak it a
little bit because for starters this
theaters not tease and secondly like I
have a weird number of T's in here right
oh you just have one T I can't just say
oh there's a con squared and there's a
ko squared so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to put one more line and I'm gonna
replace all my feeders see how there's a
too close squared 2t here and there's a
2 cos squared theta here so every Thea
I'm gonna replace with 2t ok oh sorry
oh yeah so here's the first one that's
going to become 2 T if that's become 2 T
what's this guy going to become 40 very
good it's um - lots of 2 - there you go
so if you want you can put an extra line
just to make it really obviously if you
add one to both sides you're gonna get
one plus cos 40 on this side and you're
going to get this 2 cos squared business
on the other okay but I'm happy with
that I'm gonna bring it back over here
now I'm going to say x equals 3 take
away 2 cos squared 2t is cause for t
plus 1 are you ok with that
maybe just so that you're on the right
page I'll put the extra line in here oh
this is dying fast but I just got there
via KHOU so do you see how directly I
can substitute that in ok now that's all
the trigonometric identities that I need
I just need to tidy this little mess up
what happens with the one inside the
brackets what's it going to do
hey mrs. Lee's when do we learn about
expanding brackets when is that what
year is that you rate okay you're eight
how are they with expanding brackets are
they okay with that
yeah fantastic I wonder if you hours
good oh yeah that that can be a bit of
an issue right do you think after four
years they'd be better they'd be more
comfortable yeah okay I'm stupid I'll
keep on writing if you want to you give
me an answer what's going to happen to
the plus one in the records it's gonna
become minus one which interacts with
the three leaves you with two thank you
okay oh you didn't know the answer
that's lovely
all right so so what do I do with this
right well we've just answered part a
we've put the equation in this form x
equals there's X naught right there what
do we say X naught was what's the
significance of it it's the center of
version very gonna use that in a second
and then you've got this this is my a
cos NT what's the a in this case one
it's one one so that's gonna be useful
in a minute as well and there's our M
all right fantastic now we're ready to
interpret this thing